there's an odd phenomenon in silicon
valley that no one really talks about
startup employees often make more money
than startup founders it's
counter-intuitive because tech youtubers
love to focus on billionaires like elon
musk and mark zuckerberg but the vast
majority of startups fail and when they
do the founders get nothing meanwhile
thousands of employees at high growth
startups are becoming millionaires every
single day so what do the most
successful startup employees know that
everyone else doesn't well i've broken
it down into eight steps to help you get
rich at a startup without getting lucky
of course first up is actually picking
which startup you want to join if you
can hop on a rocket ship you'll be
immensely wealthy in no time but wind up
at a startup that fails to launch and
you'll probably make nothing and quickly
be back on the job hunt so selection is
critical but how do you know if a
startup is the real deal well you
basically have to think like an investor
is this startup going to solve a big
problem are the founders extremely
talented and hardworking can this be a
viable business long term it's kind of a
terrible situation to be honest in order
to really win as a startup employee you
not only need to hustle to land a job
offer but you also have to think like an
investor and try and predict the future
of a tiny company working out of a
garage but this is the core of every
successful employee's journey they
believed when no one else did just like
those early investors so what should you
look for well first off the founding
team needs to be solid great founders
can't afford to just be smart they also
have to be incredibly hard working so
you need to dig into their previous
experiences and future plans to make
sure everything checks out does it sound
like the founders are just a bunch of
hustlers chasing the latest hype wave or
do they seem genuinely passionate about
the problem could you see the team
sticking it out when times get tough or
will they bail you also need to assess
the quality of the core problem that the
startup is trying to solve could you see
yourself using this product or
recommending it to a friend does it seem
possible to even build what the founders
are describing the company's mission
needs to sit nicely at the intersection
of ambitious but doable fortunately you
don't have to do a hundred percent of
this work yourself unless you're joining
a team on day one they've probably
raised a bit of money from investors and
those investors have hopefully done
their research if you see a bunch of big
name investors scrambling to invest in a
hot startup that could be a sign that
working there could prove lucrative but
not always see sometimes the founders
are lying to everyone including their
investors so you have to stay vigilant
about avoiding frauds there were
employees who worked at theranos for
years before the fraud was uncovered and
they walked away with nothing you don't
want to spend years of your life
grinding on a project that goes nowhere
just to wind up empty-handed so how can
you avoid joining a startup that's
destined for failure sadly you can't
just google these things but there are
ways to consistently pick winners let's
compare two high-profile biotech
companies theranos and moderna by now
everyone knows that theranos was a fraud
and moderno was a massive success but it
wasn't always that way see if you were a
talented scientist looking for a startup
job in 2014 theranose looked pretty good
elizabeth holmes had just been featured
on the cover of forbes magazine and the
press absolutely adored the company if
you just trusted the google results you
could easily end up working for a
fraudulent company and wasting years of
your life fast forward two years to 2016
and once again listening to the broad
media coverage of startups would lead
you astray see by this time theranose
had been exposed as a fraud and the
media was on high alert so they went out
looking for other secretive startups
that could potentially be frauds the
result of this search was another
spectacular misstep they claimed that
moderna could be the next theranos in
hindsight we can clearly see that this
was a phenomenally bad call madeira's
valuation soared from one billion
dollars to over a hundred billion
dollars as they delivered exactly what
they promised so just reading the
headlines would have led you to go work
at theranos and pass on an opportunity
to work at moderna insanity lots of
people didn't make this mistake though
and they made millions of dollars in the
process the solution to this comes back
to the importance of team theranos was
founded by a dropout and had no major
silicon valley investors backing the
company moderna on the other hand was
founded by a harvard professor and
backed by one of the best biotech
investment firms of all time so when
you're trying to decide if small startup
is the real deal or not it always comes
down to the people involved great people
create great companies but they also
think long term and that's something
you'll need to do if you want to make it
at a startup moderna had been working on
mrna technology for over a decade before
they found the right application and
really took off the best founding teams
are willing to grind for years before
seeing real results anyone who tries to
build a startup to get rich quick will
be in for a world of hurt it just never
works out so when you're assessing the
company you have to look to the future
the company might be extremely small
right now and the product might barely
work at the moment but if there's a seed
of something great there it could all
pay off massively this ties into
strategy around compensation packages
which we'll get to soon but you'll never
get a huge chunk of company stock the
first day you show up to work you have
to earn those shares over several years
so if you don't have a long-term mindset
you'll burn out before having an impact
one mistake that startup employees often
make is underestimating the growth that
can occur at a really successful startup
many people look at the generous pay
packages at big tech companies like
apple and microsoft and assume they can
compare those directly to smaller
startups that's a big error though see
big tech might be able to grant you
stock worth a million dollars but the
odds that your stock becomes worth 10
million dollars is very low on the other
hand fast growing startups often see
their valuations more than 10x every few
years if they're really onto something
now obviously there's more risk
associated with joining a high-growth
startup things could flatline a new
competitor could emerge or the team
could just fall apart but if you've
picked well the total economic upside is
nearly limitless once you've found the
right company and convinced yourself
that it's going to be huge in a few
years you have to actually negotiate
your offer and just as there is a risk
trade-off between working at a big
established company and a small scrappy
startup there's also a big risk
trade-off in the structure of startup
pay packages startups are always cash
strapped they aren't profitable yet and
the team is often working hard to find
product market fit that's a big part of
the reason why they offer shares in the
company as compensation it would be
impossible to get a talented engineer to
leave a cushy job in big tech and take a
massive pay cut if there wasn't a
substantial upside in general the stock
that a startup grants early employees is
meant to offset lower cash salaries but
there's always room for negotiation
sometimes people have big families to
take care of and simply can't afford to
take pay cuts so they need more cash up
front to join a startup this usually
results in a smaller stock option grant
but if you're really optimistic about
the company it can make sense to try and
lean in the other direction ask the
startup to give you as much equity as
possible and keep your living expenses
low while you grow the business if you
play your cards right that incremental
bump in equity could wind up being worth
millions and you might not actually need
to give up that much cash to get it
there are of course other ways to get a
larger stock grant at a startup the more
critical your job is the more equity
you'll get with some early executives
earning three or even five percent of
the total company basically the earlier
you join the more you'll get because
that's where you're taking the most risk
joining early isn't the only way to get
bigger stock grants though technical
roles are usually in higher demand and
that means more stock for early
engineers it's not always easy to switch
career paths but if you're young and
willing to work for it developing an
in-demand skill set will pay off
massively when you eventually join a
company management skills are also
valuable even at early stage companies
if you're someone who can come into a
startup and help scale an entire
division of the company you'll be
handsomely rewarded startups are tricky
because often you'll need to be willing
to get your hands dirty at the early
stages and build things yourself but
then quickly evolve into a good manager
as the company grows this is extremely
hard to do right especially for founders
but the most successful startup
employees i know have always had the
foresight to prepare for what's next so
you found a great company landed the job
and now you're looking at an offer
letter with a bunch of legal jargon and
can't figure out how much your stock is
actually worth don't worry you're not
alone stock options are an incredible
invention and in many ways they're a big
part of why silicon valley has been so
successful but stock options are
unfairly difficult to decipher for
startup employees so let's untangle them
founders can calculate their ownership
extremely easily when they start the
company they divide up the shares and
that's what they own investors also have
it pretty easy they buy their shares at
a set price and then they just need to
know the latest share price to value
their positions but startup employees
have a much harder time judging the
value of what they're given see in
bigger tech companies employees are
usually given restricted stock units or
rsus these are real stakes in the
company worth actual money on the day
they are granted and since these big
companies are publicly traded it's
fairly simple for employees to sell
their stock for cash whenever they want
but early stage startups are much more
complicated instead of actual stock
employees are given the option to buy
stock this is done to avoid upfront tax
burdens if a startup gave you a million
dollars of stock up front you'd have to
pay taxes on that million dollars
immediately if the startup went bankrupt
the next year you'd wind up with nothing
but a massive loss it would be terrible
so instead startups give employees stock
options that are at least in the eyes of
the government worthless you heard that
right you could join the hottest startup
and get a massive stock option grant but
when you send in your taxes you'll tell
the government that they aren't worth
anything yet that's because these
options merely give you the right to buy
the stock at a future date at a set
price now the price is determined by
what's called a 409 a valuation and with
a name like that it should be obvious
where this valuation comes from that's
right the government's tax code so
basically a team of independent
accountants tell the government what the
startup is currently worth for tax
purposes and that's the price you get to
buy your shares at in the future there's
a problem though see that 409 a
valuation is typically much lower than
what investors pay for the stock and
it's way lower than what the founders
think the stock will be worth in a few
years so how should you value your
options well the first way is to look at
the difference between the 409 a price
and the share price that investors most
recently paid if the 409 a valuation
says that each share is worth ten
dollars but investors just paid fifty
dollars per share you can reasonably
expect to make forty dollars in profit
per share but that doesn't tell the
whole story see it's very rare that
companies wind up being worth exactly
what investors paid years earlier
typically they either take off or go
bankrupt so if you're confident that the
startup you're joining is going to
become massive you should treat your
stock options like gold because they
could wind up being worth millions
that's inevitably what happens when
startup employees hit it big they get a
bunch of stock options at a very early
stage that have an extremely low price
and then every option is worth hundreds
or thousands of dollars when the company
goes public but all this focus on
material gain misses an important point
the reason that these startup employees
wind up making so much money is because
they really have a massive impact on the
startup's success startups are all about
people and it doesn't matter if you have
a visionary ceo presenting to packed
theaters if the team isn't building a
great product so once you get your stock
options you have to work hard to make
them valuable it might be possible to
get a nice equity grant at a big tech
company and spend four years basically
doing nothing but at a startup you will
kill the company get fired or both there
is a silver lining here though see most
of the time stock option grants have a
vesting schedule this means that you
don't receive the stock options up front
you have to work for them typically the
stock grant will vest over a four year
period and you won't get anything if you
leave the company within one year of
joining this is called a cliff and it's
meant to stop people from joining
collecting options and then immediately
leaving the beautiful thing about stock
is that after you've earned it say by
spending four years of sleepless nights
growing your startup you'll have that
stock forever this means that as the
company grows you can still make lots of
money if you hold on longer and this
really does happen all the time facebook
more than 10x the stock price after
going public lots of early employees had
left the company by then but they still
made a killing on their facebook stock
there is another problem though it's not
always cheap to exercise your options
especially if your startup hasn't ipo'ed
yet your stock grant might be worth
millions of dollars on paper but it
still might cost hundreds of thousands
of dollars to actually exercise the
stock options remember you didn't get
actual stock when you joined just the
right to buy stock at a later date at a
set price fortunately there are
solutions to this problem some companies
will offer what's called a cashless
exercise where they basically give you a
one-day loan to buy the shares and sell
them in the same day you don't have to
put up any of your own money and you get
the full value of your stock options
immediately there are also investors who
will loan you money to exercise your
stock options in exchange for a small
portion of the upside this can be a
win-win scenario if you're strapped for
cash but still believe that the options
will be worth a lot in the future
riskier options exist as well you could
mortgage your house to come up with the
cash but if the stock crashes you could
be in a world of hurt so be very careful
if you're taking out a loan to buy stock
options that is backed up by anything
other than the value of the options
themselves sometimes companies will
extend what's called the exercise window
to let employees hold on to their
options longer without needing to
exercise them this is great because
early employees can spend four years
working at the company then move on and
still make money from their options when
the company eventually sells or goes
public down the road no need to find the
cash to buy the options on their last
day of work people don't often talk
about what happens after you've worked
at a hugely successful startup but they
should if you're an early employee at a
big success you can kind of write your
own ticket sometimes you'll have enough
money to just sit on the beach and drink
pina coladas for the rest of your life
but it's always more exciting to see
someone double down and dive right back
into the startup world although maybe
after a few pina coladas this is the
real benefit of making an impact and a
successful startup everyone will want to
work with you we've all heard about the
paypal mafia lots of people pay
attention to what those co-founders went
on to do and that's reasonable given
that peter thiel started founder's fun
and elon musk built tesla and spacex but
there's an entire class of early paypal
employees who went on to have massive
impacts in silicon valley they didn't
need to continue working but they did
anyway because they wanted to build the
next generation of technology companies
and solve real problems big ambitious
projects are extremely hard to get off
the ground but having a major success
under your belt can unlock an entirely
new set of opportunities no one would
have given elon money to start a rocket
company before he sold paypal and i've
talked to dozens of successful startup
employees who went on to start ambitious
companies after cashing out of a
successful startup so congratulations
you're now ready to be incredibly
successful while you're working at a
startup but there's still one major
question how do you actually land the
job well i've mapped out a simple
three-step process for landing a new job
quickly in this video here so go watch
that one next thanks a lot